is there anything you said that you want
to apologize for or clarify right now
oh i don't know i'm just kidding um i
was i mean maybe for the group if we
said anything that was that offended
somebody or maybe was interpreted the
wrong way i can promise it was never
intentional um we were just out here
trying to be our authentic selves and um
sometimes you know that'll make people
happy sometimes it'll upset some people
but we never did anything to
intentionally offend anyone or hurt
anyone's feelings we were just playing
the game and kind of living our lives in
a crazy social experiment families argue
bust fight love but they still love each
other in the end and i know big d and i
had some situations i was just about to
ask you about that i was gonna say big d
and tiffany between them yeah
is like my little brother he does not
want to listen to his big sister i want
to be heard he wants to be right i just
want to say what i have to say but in
the end i don't care what big z has said
about me i love him there's nothing he
can do about it we are family we are
going to be family he has not said
anything i have not heard before i know
he has not known me all of my life but
that's fine we have spent a lot of time
together and no matter what no one's
going to make me dislike him or not love
him the way that i do and same with
everyone else we have said things we
love each other and that's all that
matters i do want to say this you know i
came in this house
you know forgetting that there's cameras
and
a lot of people right a lot of people
know that i say what i want and i have
no filter and you know each of these
individuals i look at them as family so
when i talk to them i talk to them like
if i'm talking at home
um and some of the things i probably you
know i said and obviously i've learned
that
since of getting out the house probably
came you know came across as you know
that i didn't care for the women
and i don't want any of the women to
feel that way at all
and i hope you know when everyone takes
time to watch this back if they decide
or don't decide to i hope they see that
i really did care about each and every
single one of these women in the cookout
and i told them to their face i don't
have a filter and i even said are you
okay with me saying this because i don't
want you to be offended you know me
being a gay man i talk to the girls and
we say we call each other the b-word
that's how we talk but i asked the girls
and they're like no it's fine you say it
but nobody else better say it um but you
know i just wanted to be known like
tiffany said me and tiffany we had
i mean i thought we were going to be in
a boxing match at this point she was a
tough opponent okay i thought it felt
like my dad fighting i leave with her um
that's what i was going to say she yeah
she was yeah she was tough she was like
but tiffany is somebody who i always
going to have respect for and i told her
every single time i said i wish we had
that conversation we did earlier and it
happened later and it was one of those
things where i was like well listen baby
i love you but remember this is a tv
show so don't take anything personal and
you know also to you know miss aza who's
a dear friend of mine um and like i said
i've always told her she don't owe me
anything um okay and i might have
sitting in a room all summer right right
she does she doesn't owe me anything but
i at least want her to know you know on
a national platform ozza is amazing
she's a very beautiful and smart woman
and she was a very good friend to me and
all i can do is hope that maybe one day
she will find it in the kindness of her
heart to allow me to show that same
thing back to her and if she ever
watches it back i hope that she will
understand that i really did have her
back um but you know when you get to the
end and nerves happen things happen in
many ways you're apologizing right right
now are you accepting i am apologizing
to you absolutely i'm always someone
that's a forgiving person i accept your
apology thank you okay that's awesome
and yes there will be some people who
are saying you were rough on the women
you don't like one yeah you know that
when they watch when they watch the show
yeah i'm like damn the gay ones don't
like women yeah i love women
[Music]